MARKETS THAT ARE DRIVING PEOPLE
TO THIS COUNTRY EVERY DAY.
>> Laura: LET’S GET THE
PERSPECTIVE OF SENATOR MIKE LEE
OF UTAH WHOSE NEW BOOK IS
ALREADY A HUGE "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLER.
IT’S ON MY FACEBOOK AND WEBSITE.
WRITTEN OUT OF HISTORY, THE
FORGOTTEN FOUNDERS WHO FOUGHT
FOR GOVERNMENT.
WELCOME SENATOR.
AS ALWAYS IT’S GREAT TO SEE HER.
I THINK OUR FOUNDERS WOULD BE
SHOCKED TO SEE WHAT HAS HAPPENED
TO THIS COUNTRY.
OBVIOUSLY A WHOLE DIFFERENT
SITUATION THAN OUR COUNTRY’S
FOUNDING.
YOU HEARD THE DEBATE WE JUST
HAD.
YOU HEARD THE STATISTICS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO GO
HOME, THEN THEY ALL GET TO’S
DAY.
THEY ARE RELOCATED TO CENTERS
AND WE ARE TRYING TO CHECK ON
THEM.
A LOT OF THEM ARE GOING OFF THE
GRID BECAUSE THEY DON’T WANT TO
BE DEPORTED, THEY DON’T WANT THE
KIDS TO BE DEPORTED.
IT’S A PERVERSE SYSTEM WHICH SET
UP.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT IS
BRINGING THESE PEOPLE HERE.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHY THESE
CHILDREN ARE BEING SEPARATED
FROM THEIR PARENTS.
WE HAD A GOVERNMENT THAT REFUSED
TO ENFORCE THE LAW AND A
GOVERNMENT THAT’S IT WE WILL
DEPORT YOU AND THEN DIDN’T.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS YOU END UP
BEING A MAGNET FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THAT’S OBJECTS ALL KINDS OF
CHILDREN TO EXPLOITATION, ABUSE,
ASSAULT IN MANY CASES.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE, THAT IS THE
CAUSE.
>> Laura: APPROXIMATELY 90% OF
ALL REMOVAL ORDERS, THAT MEANS
DEPORTATION ORDERS EACH YEAR
RESULT FROM A FAILURE FOR PEOPLE
TO SHOW UP AT THEIR HEARING.
THEY DON’T SHOW UP FOR THEIR
ACTUAL IMMIGRATION HEARING.
THAT’S 90% OF THE UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS ARE NOT SHOWING UP AT
HEARINGS.
SO THEY COME HERE, THEY KNOW
THEY ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
STAY HERE.
WHAT IS THE SENATE ON THE HOUSE
COOKING UP?
I HEAT, KEEP HEARING ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO COME
OUT AND AGREE TO AN AMNESTY WITH
AN END TO CHAIN MIGRATION.
IT’S NOT QUITE THE BOB GOODLATT
GOODLATTE, WHAT’S GOING ON?
>> I WOULD LOVE TO SEE IT BE THE
BOB GOODLATTE BILL.
I THINK HE’S DONE A REMARKABLE
JOB OF BALANCING COMPETING
INTERESTS.
I HOPE THEY ARE NOT COMING UP
WITH SOMETHING LIKE THAT COOKED
UP IN 2013.
THEY TOLD US WE ARE COMING UP
WITH A DEAL.
IT WAS RUMORED FOR MANY MONTHS,
YEARS IN FACT, THAT THEY WERE
WORKING ON IT.
AND IT WAS ABOUT A THOUSAND
PAGES OF SOMETHING NOBODY HAD
READ.
PEOPLE VOTED FOR IT ANYWAY AND
THEN THEY SWITCHED IT AND
REPLACED IT WITH A DIFFERENT
BILL.
I FEAR THEY MIGHT BE DOING THE
SAME THING AND I THINK THEY
REMEMBER THE CONSEQUENCE.
>> Laura: THE FREEDOM CAUCUS
DOESN’T WANT IT.
THEY ARE TO COME OUT AND SAID WE
DON’T WANT AMNESTY, BUT CAN YOU
GET SOMETHING POSITIVE?
YOU COULD END HIS CHAIN
MIGRATION.
THAT IS A HUGE AMPLIFIER OF
IMMIGRATION IN THE COUNTRY,
NONMERIT-BASED.
THAT’S A BIG DRIVER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT’S ONE OF THE THINGS I LIKE
ABOUT THE GOODLATTE PROPOSAL.
IT ADDRESSES THAT AN ADDRESSES
THE DACA SITUATION.
IT DOES SO IN A RESPONSIBLE
MANNER THAT SHUTS OFF THE
MAGNET.
>> Laura: I WANT TO ASK ABOUT
THE OTHER NEWS OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS, YOUR COLLEAGUE MARCO RUBIO
SAID SOMETHING I THINK
INTERESTING ON ABC THIS WEEK.
I WOULD LIKE YOUR REACTION,
LET’S WATCH.
>> IT APPEARS THAT THERE WAS AN
INVESTIGATION OUT OF THE
CAMPAIGN BUT IF CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE A HISTORY
THAT WE SHOULD BE SUSPICIOUS OF
THAT PREDATE THIS PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN 2015-16.
THE FBI SHOULD LOOK AT PEOPLE
LIKE THAT BUT THEY ARE NOT
INVESTIGATING THE CAMPAIGN.
>> SO YOU ARE SAYING
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS WRONG?
>> I HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE THAT
THOSE PEOPLE WERE PART OF AN
INVESTIGATION ON THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Laura: YOUR REACTION?
>> HIS FINAL STATEMENT MIGHT BE
TRUE.
HE MAY HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE OF
ANY SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
IT DOESN’T MEAN IT DIDN’T
HAPPEN.
I THINK IT’S VERY DIFFICULT TO
PROVE THAT A DOG DIDN’T BARK.
I DON’T THINK HE SAYING HE
DIDN’T --
>> Laura: YOU’VE GOT RUBIO, WE
WILL PLAY A SOUND BITE LATER ON
FROM TREY GOWDY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
WHO SEEM TO BE WORKING OVERTIME.
A LOT OF THEM DIDN’T SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT, WORKING OVERTIME TO
BUILD A BOB MUELLER, THE MUELLER
TEAM.
I THINK FROM THE VERY BEGINNING